scp-682 vs scp-3922  who would win in this matchup between  the indestructible reptile and the tv  reality filter 3922 is a small cylinder  that when placed near a television will  alter the content of any fictional  material being played to include a  battalion of heavily armed soldiers who  proceed to arrest the characters in the  film and try them for their crimes the  foundation introduced 3922 to security  footage of 682 the tape was then altered  into a 72-hour military epic in which a  coalition of soldiers all played by  deceased actors attempted to terminate  682 over the course of the film the film  ends with a final remaining soldier  played by patrick swayze alongside  several gigantic primates staring down  682 and preparing to duke it out once  and for all before a 2b continued title  card is displayed talk about a sequel  hook